Pock, pock, pock.
Pock, pock, pock, pock, pock.
So.
Ich bin spontan am Start.
Ich weiß, es ist spät.
20.15 Uhr.
Äh, nicht 20.15 Uhr, Alter.
20.50 Uhr.
20.15 Uhr wäre noch fast normal.
20.50 Uhr ist ein bisschen...
nicht normal.
Aber sind schon die ersten Leute am Start.
Ich werde heute auch wahrscheinlich nicht so alt.
Spätestens 23 Uhr.
Aber alle, alle spätestens 23 Uhr.
Das Dumme ist wieder...
Eigentlich hatte ich vor...
Was macht mein Mauszeiger da oben eigentlich?
IQ Boost.
Pock.
Excellent.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive IQ Boost, ja.
Für alle Anwesenden.
Sind erst 27.
Rest hat Pech.
Nee, das liegt...
Nee, nee.
Nee, bin ich nicht.
Das liegt daran,
ich hab den ganzen Tag hier wieder vorm Rechner gehockt,
kein Wort gesagt.
Und jetzt, äh...
Ich rede heute zum ersten Mal.
Quasi. Länger.
Am Stück.
Nö, nö, ist nix.
Das legt sich gleich wieder.
Kreiselcrank heute, ja.
Ich hab richtig, richtig
harten Kreiselcrank gemacht.
Ich wurde geflamed ingame. Stellt euch mal vor.
Ich wurde geflamed.
Und eigentlich liegt's mal wieder daran,
weil die Noobs den Heli geflogen sind.
Nee, aber sowas in der Richtung.
Jetzt haben wir den in den Kram nicht geschissen bekommen
und ich bin einfach losgelaufen, ne.
Ist halt so.
Ich warte nicht 500 Mal,
bis die Leute recouped haben.
Vor allem, wenn's ums Leveln geht,
da renne ich halt einfach los.
Und wenn die Leute nicht hinterherkommen,
obwohl ich eine Minute gewartet habe,
haben sie Pech.
Ich kann ja immer eine Viertelstunde warten,
bis alle sich den Finger aus dem Puppus gezogen haben.
Damit sie mal wieder spielen können.
Pech gehabt.
Da muss Progress gemacht werden.
Progress.
Wenn kein Progress gemacht wird,
so geht nicht der richtige Kreiselcrank.
Ja.
Wenn alle da sind, muss ich euch was
sehr Lustiges erzählen.
Nicht, betrifft mich persönlich nicht,
hab ich vorhin gelesen.
Wow, ist ja gut.
Mach die Playlist, please, noch lauter.
Ich mag Playlists nicht.
Die unterschiedlich laut sind.
Unterschiedlich laut der Songs.
Das ist immer ziemlich...
Pain.
Was machen wir heute?
Guckt ihr den Titel an, da siehst du es.
Ich habe nichts vorbereitet.
Bei mir ist es in letzter Zeit echt schwierig,
so Subs-
Streams mit Technik-IQ-
High-IQ-Substanz zu machen.
Weil da muss ich mir was überlegen.
Und ich darf auch noch nicht abends
irgendwie total kaputt im Kopf sein,
dass ich das auf die Reihe kriege.
Das ist schwierig.
nach Kreiselgrind gemacht habe, klappt das nicht.
Wenn ich arbeiten war, klappt das nicht.
Da haben sich die ganzen Reaction-Streamer
einfacher. Die müssen
nächstes Mal zusammen löten oder programmieren im Stream.
Community-Gear ist am Start.
Ja. Also Chat,
wenn wir über 100 Leute sind,
das dauert ja meistens immer kurz,
bis dann alle da sind, oder sagen wir mal 150
Leute, da muss ich euch was Lustiges
erzählen. Habe ich vorhin gelesen, habe ich mir gedacht,
das kann doch echt nicht wahr sein.
Vielleicht hat es der ein oder andere
von euch auch schon mitbekommen.
Aber ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich habe zumindest noch nichts im Chat darüber gelesen bisher.
So, wir machen mal kurz Archlinux
by the way an.
Und installieren eine Runde Package-Updates.
Warum? Weil Archlinux.
Sicherlich 30.000
Package-Updates gekriegt.
Hackman.
Massive geheimes Passwort, kommt hier nie drauf.
Wie? Was ist das?
Nur 26 Packages.
Das ist aber
schwach. Archlinux.
Oh, was ist da oben?
Was?
Warum zum Teufel habe ich ClusterFS
installiert? Also nicht mit C.
Ne, Gluster. GlusterFS
überhaupt installiert.
Blödsinn.
Seit Jahrzehnten quasi schon nie mal verwendet.
Kann ich mal übertrieben.
Was hast du mitbekommen?
Ne, warum?
Hessische Automatenläden müssen sonntags schließen.
Ach, das verstehst du bestimmt wieder
gegen irgendwelche Richtlinien oder so.
Der Einzelhändler Tegut
muss sich in Hessen an das Sonntagsverbot halten.
Die seelische Erhebung
Die seelische, was?
Die seelische Erhebung.
Ich versuche mir gerade vorzustellen,
was die seelische Erhebung ist.
Die seelische Erhebung
an Sonn- und Feiertagen
müsste geschützt werden.
Okay, das ist irgendwas Gläubiges.
Pregel, Pregel-Time.
Was anderes kann das nicht sein.
Ja, aber wo ist denn das Problem?
Was ist das Problem?
Da arbeitet keiner.
Da gehen die Leute rein,
bezahlen automatisch,
also bezahlen wahrscheinlich
per Handy oder so.
Da müssen keine Leute drin sein.
Ja, verstehe ich das Problem.
Wisst ihr,
das ist auch so ein Ding.
Ich meine,
das ist sicherlich alles rechtlich
und so,
das muss so sein.
Aber man muss halt echt sagen,
wir sind solche Korinthen-Kacker
und Bürokratie-Liebhaber hier.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Ich hoffe ja irgendwann drauf,
aber das werden wir nicht mehr erleben.
dass wir es mal hinkriegen,
so ein Zwischending zu machen,
zwischen dem,
wie es die Chinesen machen
und wie wir es machen.
Also, dass man quasi nicht,
wenn man irgendwas baut,
15 Bauarbeiter aus Versehen einbetoniert
im Fundament,
aber halt auch nicht 15 Jahre braucht,
bis der Antrag durch ist,
dass überhaupt angefangen werden darf,
was zu bauen.
So was dazwischen wäre eigentlich ganz nice.
Aber ich glaube,
da hoffe ich vergebens,
dass das klappt.
Ich hoffe, da ist nichts geprägt.
Ist da irgendwas bekannt?
Ja.
Also, ich bin dafür,
dass an jedem Feiertag
jeder Religion automatisch keiner arbeiten muss.
Ja, bin ich sofort dabei.
Ich bin sogar dafür,
dass man, also,
dann würde ich sogar selbst eine Religion gründen,
wo es Feiertage gibt.
Ansonsten habe ich damit ja nichts am Hut,
aber dafür könnte ich eine Ausnahme machen.
Ich glaube,
dass das gar nichts mit etwas Christlichem zu tun hat.
Das Gesetz stammt vielleicht nicht,
aber ich glaube,
dass das gar nichts mit etwas Christlichem zu tun hat.
Das ist vielleicht noch aus einer Zeit,
wo das wichtig war
und das ist jetzt halt da
und muss beachtet werden.
Ich glaube,
da wird heute kein Hahn mehr danach krähen.
Ja.
Church Champ,
nicht Champ,
machen wir wenn schon.
Die Kirche kann viel mögen,
wenn er taglang ist.
Solange es da kein Gesetz so gibt,
ist das wurscht.
Und das gibt es ja anscheinend.
Dementsprechend müssen die sich dran halten.
Da müsste ich halt mal hinterfragen,
ob das Gesetz so sinnvoll ist.
Beziehungsweise,
ob man das nicht,
ob man das nicht irgendwie ergänzen kann,
weil prinzipiell finde ich ja schon sinnvoll,
dass wir sowas wie Wochenende haben.
Ja.
So.
Arch Linux rebootet.
Sieht gut aus.
Okay, Leute.
Ich habe ja gesagt,
ich erzähle euch was Lustiges,
wenn alle da sind.
Fehlen noch ein paar Leute.
Es ist,
es ist keck,
Leute,
es ist keck JavaScript-Time.
Moin, Max.
Kurze Frage.
Ich bin aktuell in der IT
als normaler Admin
Windows-Infrastruktur-Bereich
und würde gerne etwas
im Coding-Bereich lernen.
Hab noch ein paar Fragen.
Ich habe noch keine,
nenn es lieber Programmieren
und Softwareentwicklung.
Ich, das mag,
das Wort mag keiner.
Aber,
hab noch keine Ahnung,
welchen Job ich danach
damit machen kann.
Hast du irgendwelche Empfehlungen?
Naja, erstmal solltest du dir überlegen,
was du eigentlich machen willst.
Also, was du,
was du,
ich meine,
das ist sehr vage.
Das ist genauso,
wenn ich sage,
ich möchte was im Admin-Bereich machen.
Das kann auch alles Mögliche sein.
Also, was dir gefällt.
Ich meine,
es gibt ja nicht nur
Backend, Frontend,
so als Unterscheidung.
Je nach,
je nach,
je nach Technologie.
Du hast ja ganz viele Sachen.
Backend, Frontend, Mobile,
irgendwelche Servergeschichten,
Cloud-Native-Sachen,
Tools,
unterschiedlichsten Frameworks,
unterschiedlichen Sprachen.
Musst du erstmal überlegen,
was du machen willst.
Host, ja.
Gibt noch Leute,
die machen Cobol.
Ihr benutzt jetzt Slack auf der Arbeit.
Max, nee, machen wir nicht.
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Aber Keck-JavaScript, Leute.
Ich, ich muss euch,
ich wollte, ich weiß,
ich wollte warten,
bis, bis alle da sind.
Es sind noch nicht alle da,
aber ich muss euch das jetzt erzählen,
weil ich hab mich so kaputt gelacht vorhin.
Das ist so typisch Keck-JavaScript.
Chat,
nicht nachgucken.
Nicht nach,
ups,
nicht nachgucken.
Jeder kann einfach nachgucken.
Ähm,
sagt euch,
äh, Moment,
Moment.
Fuck.
Okay, jetzt,
jetzt kann ich.
Also, sagt euch,
sagt euch,
everything,
das NPM-Package,
everything, was?
Nicht nachgucken.
Ich will einfach nur wissen,
ob ihr es,
ob ihr es mitbekommen habt.
Ich will einfach nur wissen,
Es ist wieder komplettes JavaScript.
Ja,
es ist wieder kompletter JavaScript-Schwachsinn.
Also, ich erklär,
ich erklär euch das mal kurz so in meinen Worten.
Da gucken wir uns auch noch mal irgendwie Newsartikel dazu an oder so.
Also,
ihr kennt ja alle,
zumindest alle,
die ein bisschen was mit,
ähm,
ist das so eine Joke-Package wie Not Even?
Ja, aber schlimmer.
Ne?
Also,
ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich alle,
die ein bisschen was Frontend-mäßiges
bisher gemacht haben.
Ihr kennt wahrscheinlich NPM.
NPM ist zwei Dinger.
NPM ist eine Package Registry
für JavaScript-Packages
und gleichermaßen auch das offizielle,
ja,
Node.js
Package Manager Tool.
So,
das Ding ist voll,
ich kann euch sagen,
dass hier kann jeder Depp hingehen
und Packages veröffentlichen.
Was, was auch, was auch okay ist, ja?
Ich mein,
ja, da gibt es dann so tolle Sachen wie
is even als Package zum Beispiel.
Was drei Zeilen im Endeffekt enthält.
Was nur 162.000 oder nur 163.000 weekly, weekly Downloads hat.
Also, das ist mehr als ich aktuell auf YouTube Views in der Woche hab, ey.
Ja.
Mach ich jetzt das mal seriös.
Was will ich von den Ab grit?
Wenn, dann wenn ich mal was hochladen würde,
dann ist es zwar ein bissl mehr aber,
So.
Und jetzt,
ist das so,
dass vor ein paar Jahren,
vielleicht kann sich da noch einer dran erinnern,
Vor ein paar Jahren hat einer mal ein Package unpublished.
Ich weiß nicht mehr welches Package das war,
Aber,
das war ein Package...
äh,
Leftshift.
Leftshift war das Package.
Jetzt weiß ein paar ihr.
Left... oder,
Shift leht...
nee, ne, Leftshift hießta es, glaub ich.
Das war so ein Mini Package.
Package hochgeladen und ganz viele andere
Packages hatten das als Dependency
drin. Nicht is even, sondern ein
anderes. Und der hat dann sein
Package unpublished und gelöscht auf
npm. Daraufhin
ist das halbe
Internet zusammengebrochen, weil irgend so ein
random Dude in drei Zeilen
JavaScript Package gelöscht hat.
So, und daraufhin ist
npm hingegangen und hat gesagt, hey,
wenn es Dependencies auf eine
Package-Version gibt, dann darf diese
Package-Version nicht mehr gelöscht werden,
selbst vom Maintainer. Also mal
angenommen, um das jetzt mal
euch zu erklären,
mal angenommen, ihr veröffentlicht ein
Package mit der Version 0.5
und irgendjemand
auf der Welt verwendet dieses
Package mit Version 0.5
und ihr habt festgestellt,
ihr habt
zufällig
eure private Handynummer mit
committed in den Source-Code oder irgendwas,
wo ihr garantiert nicht wollt, dass
das irgendjemand sieht, committed
und
oder mit
published in dem Package. Ja, wie der
Chrome-Typ, der irgendwelche
was war das?
Furry-Porn-Bilder in
seinem Chromium-Fork drin hatte.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt zufälligerweise
ein Package Version 0.5 veröffentlicht
und, ja,
genau, das meine ich, und habt da
zufälligerweise, warum auch immer,
Furry-Porn mit committed. So, und da
wollt ihr das Package wieder unpublishen
und dann geht das nicht, das Package zu
unpublishen, weil, naja, es
gibt eine Dependency auf das Package.
Das heißt, ihr kriegt das
nicht mehr raus. So, und jetzt,
und jetzt kommt der, und jetzt kommt
der Hit, jetzt kommt der Witz an der ganzen
Sache. Irgendjemand hat sich jetzt
einen Spaß draus gemacht und hat
ein NPM-Package erstellt,
was alle weiteren NPM-Packages
als Dependency erhält.
Der hat quasi die komplette NPM-Registry
durchgecrawled und
hat jedes Package, egal wie
alt, egal wie maintained, egal
wie es ist, jedes Package, also,
hunderte, tausende,
zehntausende Packages
als Dependency eingetragen
und hat dieses Package
veröffentlicht. Und jetzt dürft
ihr mal raten, was passiert ist.
Richtig feifert der Dude.
Da kann man sich, also, das erste ist,
das erste ist, man sollte
nicht auf die Idee kommen, dieses Package zu installieren,
weil das hier jede SSD
und alles, was es auf der Welt gibt, sprengt.
Du installierst damit wirklich sprichwörtlich
das Internet, wenn du NPM-Install
everything gemacht hast.
Ja, das kannst du, das kannst du
vergessen. So, also,
GitHub, Everything, JS,
wir können uns das auch hier kurz angucken.
Das gibt es nicht mal, das Repo, das wurde,
ne, öh,
ne, ne, NPM.
Ja, das wurde gelöscht mittlerweile, es ist
weg. Wir können noch
die, können noch die Cache-Seite angucken.
Die gibt's witzigerweise
noch.
So, NPM-Install-Everything.
Er hat extra hingeschrieben,
Achtung, Warnung,
Achtung, Warnung, don't install this.
So, jetzt gab's
bloß ein Problem.
Jetzt gab's bloß, pass mal auf,
das allerlustigste kommt zum Schluss.
So, und jetzt gab's ein Problem.
Dadurch,
dass der jedes, egal wie kleine
Furz-Package auf einmal als Dependency
drin hatte, konnten ganz viele
Leute ihre
Packages auf NPM nicht mehr,
ja, wie heißt das,
die Listen, die, die,
die Subscriber,
die Subscriben, löschen,
ja, auf gut Deutsch. Das hat natürlich
viele Leute abgefuckt, weil da haben
irgendwelche Leute
Test anpublishen, ja, die, die
publishen. Da haben viele Leute halt einfach
Testsachen hochgepusht
und wollten's halt nie veröffentlichen, so.
Konnten sie nicht mehr löschen, wegen NPM-Policy.
Das hat wieder richtig
Probleme in der JavaScript-Welt verursacht.
Und jetzt kommt's,
und jetzt kommt's, da musste ich mich so weglachen,
so wegpissen, Freund.
Irgendwann hat der Typ das dann kapiert,
dass es keine allzu gute Idee war,
das, äh,
so ein Everything-Package zu
veröffentlichen.
Und wisst ihr, was er dann machen wollte?
Wisst ihr, was er dann machen wollte?
Nachdem er festgestellt hat, dass es eine dumme Idee
war, das Internet, das JavaScript-Ökosystem
lahmzulegen,
er wollte das Package löschen.
Das ging aber nicht,
weil's schon Leute als Dependency
drin hatten.
Hahaha!
Es ging nicht mehr weg!
Es war für immer da!
Kein JavaScript, Alter!
Da musste ich mich so wegschmeißen, Freund!
Naja, zumindest,
es ging dann doch
glimpflich aus.
Es ging dann doch glimpflich aus,
denn es wurde
von,
von nem NPM-Mods
wurde das dann wieder entfernt.
Er hat das GitHub-Repo auch gelöscht.
Aber das ist, also ganz ehrlich,
JavaScript-Package-Management,
das ist so eine Shitshow!
Das ist absoluter Wahnsinn, Alter!
Ich mein,
nicht nur,
dass wenn du bei irgendeinem popeligen Projekt
NPM, äh, bei Rust, das ist ja fast, fast
schon genauso schlimm mittlerweile, ja,
wenn du da irgendwie NPM-Update machst,
dass du zig Milliarden
Packages bekommst, oder ein NPM-Installer
in einem neu geklonten Projekt,
dann 1500 Packages bekommst,
3,5 Gig Node Models,
3,5 Gig Node Models ist wahrscheinlich noch relativ, äh,
wenig.
Dazu kommt noch,
dass ganz lange
NPM irgendwelche
lokalen Build-Scripts ausgeführt hat.
Ich weiß, weiß irgendjemand, ob das immer noch
so ist? Also du konntest ja total
easy irgendwelche Malware verbreiten
früher mit NPM.
Weil einfach Post-Install-Scripts ausgeführt wurden.
Dann stand da drinnen, ja,
lade Malware.exe runter und führ aus.
So, und
mal gucken, ob Golem oder so
noch ein bisschen...
When everything becomes too much.
Socket.dev, klingt wie nach
irgendeiner, kennt die Seite jemand? Klingt, äh,
klingt wie, ähm, irgendeine
AI-generierte Sache, aber,
ja. Everything Package
contains 3000
plus Sub-Packages, die selbst wiederum
Dependencies enthalten.
Das finde ich auch geil. Der Autor
selbst hat diese Domain hier sich
gekauft und dort dann
quasi Sachen gepostet,
was er für Chaos verursacht hat.
Ja.
Und dann wollte er es löschen.
Und dann wollte er es löschen. Genau.
Ironically, the policy trapped
in its own... Genau.
Er hat festgestellt, dass
es keine doofe Idee ist. Und dann wollte er
sein Everything Package entfernen, aber es ging nicht.
Und dann hat er die NPM-Mods
angeschrieben. Und die NPM-Mods,
die haben es dann wahrscheinlich
irgendwann wieder gefixt.
Es ist... Also, JavaScript-Ökosystem
ist halt echt Riesenschitschau.
Ach, da gibt's
ein Video zu!
Ach, da gibt's ein Video zu.
Interessant.
So, I don't care.
Naja, das ist...
Ich mein, wir müssen die Story jetzt nicht über 30
Minuten ausdehnen. Aber ich find's geil.
Lass das mal wieder...
Es ist doch... Es vergeht kein Monat, bis
nicht irgendwelche JavaScripts
NPM
weirde Sachen
passieren. Das war aber echt
massive keck JavaScript, ja.
Gehen meine Emotes zwar wieder
nicht? Keck JavaScript?
Doch, geht doch. So hier.
Keck JavaScript.
Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Wie war Weihnachten und Silvester?
Weihnachtlich und Silvesterig.
Was soll ich dazu sagen? Das war...
Äh, viel gefressen
hab ich, ja.
Massive. Ich hab's sogar wieder ein bisschen
zugenommen. Massive gefressen hab ich.
Ultraviel gefressen hab ich, ja.
Ist jetzt aber schon wieder ein bisschen besser.
Und morgen
früh mach ich zum ersten Mal
wieder meine 11 Kilometer Runde.
Übrigens, heute war kurz
1.1.1.1 weg.
Ist das auch jemandem aufgefallen?
Mal gucken, ob's da... Gibt's dazu irgendwelche News,
dass der DNS weg war?
Der war nämlich heute
kurz weg.
Nö. Nicht dazu. Der war
kurzzeitig für eine halbe Minute
oder für eine Minute nicht erreichbar.
1.1.1.1.
Vielleicht war auch der Server selbst,
ich mein, das sind mehrere weltweit,
relativ sicher.
Vielleicht war's auch irgendeine Routing-Geschichte.
Das ist ja garantiert per Anycast
geregelt.
Die Erreichbarkeit von 1.1.1.1.
GitHub war...
Ach, mal wieder. Mal wieder.
Okay.
Einer hat Startcoin in ein Package gepuffert
auf der Independention von vielen Riesenprojekten.
Okay.
Also, was ich mal mitbekommen habe,
ist, dass irgendjemand
ein...
Was war das? Donation-Aufruf?
Oder...
Ich weiß nicht mal, was es war. Und da war auch
riesen Shitstorm am Start.
Und es gab mal den Fall,
dass irgendjemand
versucht... Genau!
Jetzt weiß ich's wieder. Irgendjemand hat auch mal
in sein Package eingebaut, aber das war ein .NET-Package.
Also man sieht, das kann auch...
Das muss nicht zwangsläufig immer JavaScript sein.
Das war ein .NET-Package.
Ich hab vergessen, was das genau gewesen ist.
Mock. Mock war das.
Es hat irgendjemand in sein .NET-Package
eingebaut,
dass die
E-Mail-Adresse,
wenn man sich in einem Git-Repo befindet,
die E-Mail-Adresse ausgelesen wird.
Und gehasht zu irgendeinem
Service geschickt wird.
Das war Mock, glaub ich.
Was ist da eigentlich rausgekommen?
Es wird wahrscheinlich immer noch verwendet.
Was ich auch...
Wo ich mir auch denke, die ganzen Leute
da... Aber die sind wieder komplett
übers Ziel rausgeschossen auch.
Es war ne
blöde Idee.
Es war ne wirklich... Das wurde wieder rausgebaut!
Aha! Aha!
Ich mein, es war ne blöde Idee,
aber die Leute haben's wieder komplett übertrieben
mit dem Rumgeflame.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Komplett übertrieben.
Ich hab heut wieder
einen YouTube-Comment gekriegt, wo ich mir gedacht hab,
manche Leute
haben echt krasse Fantasie.
Es ging...
Es war unter diesem Video
hier.
Linux ist kein Ersatz für Windows.
Da krieg ich ja übrigens
regelmäßig Kommentare. Das sind relativ viele Kommentare.
Krieg ich ja immer noch regelmäßig,
fast täglich...
Okay, hier mal Zwischenstrich.
Zwischenstrich immer wieder Kommentare,
wo sich dann entweder Leute
das Video nicht richtig angeguckt haben,
oder aber irgendwelche Leute, die
sich das Video nicht richtig angeguckt haben.
Oder 30 Sekunden
und dann irgendwelche Sachen hier
von sich geben, wo ich immer denke,
das hat doch mit dem Video überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Und außerdem hab ich das überhaupt nicht so gesagt,
wie ihr das da schon... Egal.
Zumindest heute
kam er hier.
Speedy47.
Und der hat
wirklich den Vogel abgeschossen
mit diesem Kommentar.
Das muss ich euch hier mal zeigen.
Das muss ich jetzt mal hier zum Besten geben.
Das ist eines der weirdesten Kommentare,
die ich in letzter Zeit auf YouTube gekriegt hab.
Passt mal auf.
Also es geht, wie gesagt, in dem Video geht es
darum, dass Linux kein
Ersatz für Windows ist.
Was hast du geantwortet?
Sehen wir gleich.
Er schreibt hier...
Allein schon...
Also er fängt hier an mit...
Eine einfache, zu bedienende
User-Oberfläche
hat eigentlich nur
Nachteile und gilt alles nur zur
Unterhaltung. Unterhalten.
Smiley.
Die Frage...
Das ist... Moment, Leute.
Das ist Big-Cag-Alu-Time, das gesamte Ding.
Massive-Cag-Alu.
Die Frage ist nicht
Windows-Linux, sondern es geht um
die Kompetenz der Menschen.
Ja, das mag es tatsächlich sein.
Ähm...
Win und das OS von Apple...
Die Musik passt eigentlich ganz gut.
Win und das OS von Apple sind ja auch behindertengerecht
gemacht, damit jeder
Vollidiot
ein Rechnen bedienen kann
und sich die
schwasinnige Unterhaltung
reinziehen kann.
Ich habe bis
20 PC programmiert.
Das war mir
zu einfach, glaube ich sofort.
Too easy.
Das war mir zu einfach und zu langweilig.
Denn Rechner macht immer, was man
ihm sagt.
Dann habe ich damit angefangen, Menschen zu
programmieren.
Alles klar. Okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Das war im Discord.
Ja, das habe ich im Discord gepostet.
So. Am Anfang etwas schwieriger
als ein Rechner.
Aber mit der Zeit wesentlich
einfacher.
Denn ich muss nur schauen, dass die Menschen
sich immer und immer wieder den selben
Scheiß ansehen. Was übrigens alles sehr
viel mit Linux ist, kein Ersatz für Windows zu tun hat.
So, und jetzt geht's
jetzt geht's richtig los.
Was ich wohl damit
sagen will. Ja, das frage ich mich tatsächlich
auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob
sich das selbst, ob ihm selbst
klar ist, was er sich damit sagen, was er
damit sagen will.
Was ich wohl damit sagen will.
Die Frage ist nicht, ob Win oder
Linux, sondern die Frage ist, wozu brauche
ich einen Rechner, um mich klein
zu halten. Nachrichten,
Textverarbeitung,
Kapitalismus.
Das Kommentar könnte auch
schon wieder... Wisst ihr, normalerweise denke ich,
sowas ist getrollt. Sowas ist halt einfach
debated. Zweifelsfall, dass ich's
lustig finde. Aber das ist so
abgedreht, das glaube ich schon wieder.
Das glaube ich schon wieder fast,
dass er das ernst meint. Kapitalismus.
Fragt
euch mal, ob es das braucht.
Eine Rechenmaschine ist nichts
anderes, als dazu da
die Menschen zu knechten.
Sie mit dummer
Unterhaltung und Beschäftigung also
ist ein Rechner nichts anderes
als ein Compiler, um
euch zu programmieren.
Es gibt auch sinnvolle Aufgaben
von Rechner, aber für diese
Aufgaben braucht man weder ein
Betriebssystem noch ein Monitor.
Ah, ja.
Alles klar. Als
Antwort ist mir da auch nichts anderes dazu eingefallen.
Alles klar.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Also wir...
Jetzt wissen wir auch, ein Rechner ist dazu da,
um euch zu compilen.
Ich weiß nicht, was mit dem los ist.
Das ist
wirklich eines der geilsten Comments in letzter
Zeit gewesen und normalerweise
fall ich...
Normalerweise fall ich auf so
Sachen schwierig rein nur noch
mittlerweile, ja. Weil ich
die meisten Sachen schlicht und ergreifend
Wo war man denn hier?
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hier...
Gar nicht
vollnehme und nicht glaube, was...
Ich gehe immer davon aus, dass das getrollt
ist, okay? Aber das ist
so abgedreht, da muss sich
einer entweder extrem
viel Mühe gegeben haben,
dass...
dass ich es quasi nicht erkenne
als Gbait oder sonst was
und dann hat er es fast schon verdient, dass man
drauf eingeht, oder
er meint es ernst und ich vermute,
er meint das ernst.
Das ist auch nicht AI geschrieben.
Das sieht nicht nach einem typischen AI Text aus.
Ich habe mal ein neues Video hochgenommen und
hochgeladen, aber noch nicht freigeschaltet, weil das viel zu spät
gewesen wäre.
Als wäre dann erst
um 17, 18 Uhr oder so
oben. Ja, viel zu...
Ich meine, du kannst ChatGPT bestimmt sagen,
mache random Rechtschreibfehler.
Ja.
Also,
also ich würde bevorzugt mich von einem
IBM Großrechner mal
kompilieren lassen,
weil wir auch so wissen, wie das ist.
Also denkt dran, Rechner sind nur da, um euch
zu kompilieren.
Also die Leute, muss man echt sagen, habe ich ja auch
auf Twitter geschrieben, sorry
auf X. Manche Leute haben echt wilde
Fantasien, als sie was mit
denen los ist.
Ich glaube,
da versagt die AI noch.
Ich glaube, das kriegt ChatGPT noch
nicht so hin.
Kompilier mich.
Das kriegt ChatGPT glaube ich noch nicht hin.
Hat nicht oben jemand was
gefragt? Wollte ich noch was zu sagen?
Was hältst du von Jobhopping?
Also zwei bis drei Jahre wechseln
und sein Gehalt zu steigern.
Wenn du damit dein Gehalt steigern kannst, warum nicht?
Also wenn das für dich
die Priorität Nummer eins ist, warum nicht?
Ich denke immer,
Gehalt ist, okay, ich muss das
anders sagen, Gehalt ist wahrscheinlich für jeden
Priorität eins. Oder ChatGPT?
Meine Frage an euch. An alle, die,
wenn es nicht eure Firma ist,
alle, die irgendwo angestellt sind und arbeiten,
was ist für euch,
ist für jemand von euch Gehalt
nicht Nummer eins?
Von der Wichtigkeit her.
Letztendlich sind wir uns ja einig, das Gesamtpaket muss
stimmen, aber wenn man das mal so
abstufen würde, würde ich sagen,
Gehalt ist auf jeden Fall Stufe eins.
Ja. Natürlich
ist das alles immer ein bisschen
gestaffelt, also wenn es bei einem
jetzt ein Euro mehr gibt und der Rest scheiße
ist, gehe ich trotzdem nicht dahin, nur weil es ein Euro
mehr, wisst ihr,
verstehe ich.
Ja gut, also ich denke mal,
prinzipiell ist Gehalt erstmal Nummer eins
bei den Sachen, dass man guckt
und wenn das dein Ziel ist,
in möglichst schnell
da
gehaltstechnisch aufzusteigen,
ich sehe da kein Problem drin.
Du bist ja mit dem Laden nicht verheiratet,
du kannst das ja einfach machen.
Wenn du was Gutes, Neues findest,
ich finde das nicht verwerflich.
Für mich, ich hätte keinen Bock drauf,
ich meine, zwei bis drei Jahren, das ist so
die Zeit, wo man sich so richtig dran gewöhnt hat,
weiß, wie es in dem jeweiligen Laden läuft,
sich
ein bisschen, was die organisatorischen
Sachen angeht, zurücklehnen kann, weil
man nicht jetzt laufen gucken muss, wie geht
was, du weißt, wie die Sachen gemacht werden, wie die
Prozesse laufen, wen du für was fragen willst,
wen du für was fragen musst, wenn du was wissen
willst, also
nach zwei bis drei Jahren ist es meistens dann
deutlich gechillter nochmal, deswegen
dann gerade wechseln, aber
wenn man das von den Skills
her machen kann, wenn das von der
persönlichen, ja, so
Lebensplanung und so passt
und das Wichtigste ist, das Gehalt zu steigern
möglichst schnell, dann ist das bestimmt
nicht verkehrt, also ich finde da überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches
dran. Warum fragst du, willst du das machen?
Wieder Job wechseln, du hast doch
erst, du hast ja nicht letztens erst geschrieben, du hast einen neuen Job.
Ich
bilde mir ein, oder zumindest, ich weiß nicht, ob es du das
warst, aber irgendjemand, der einen ähnlichen Namen hatte,
glaube ich, also insofern,
ja, also ich finde es nicht verwerflich.
Du hast ja, du bist
seit drei Monaten im neuen Laden, siehst du, da habe ich,
das dachte ich mir doch, also ich finde da
überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches dran, man
muss das immer so sehen, also wie gesagt, für mich persönlich
wäre das jetzt nicht unbedingt was, aber
man muss es mal so sehen, umgedreht
würden es die
meisten Arbeitgeber mit euch auch machen,
wenn es irgendwelche Probleme gibt, wenn irgendwas
nicht passt, dann würden die auch sagen,
ey, hier, macht schon mal vom Acker.
Also, warum solltest du das nicht auch
machen? Ich sehe da überhaupt nichts Verwerfliches
dran, für mich, für mich persönlich wäre das
jetzt nichts. Freizeit, Arbeitszeit
ist wichtiger, ja, ich meine,
wie gesagt,
so sehe ich das ja auch, dass das Gesamtpaket
stimmen muss, aber von der Priorität
her ist bei mir Gehalt schon das
das überste, fast gleichauf
bei Gehalt ist mittlerweile
bei mir tatsächlich Homeoffice, muss ich ganz ehrlich
sagen, also ich würde sogar,
ich würde sogar auf
bisschen Gehalt verzichten,
wenn ich
dadurch quasi bessere Homeoffice-Möglichkeiten hätte,
aber die habe ich bei mir, ich kriege jetzt ja viel
Kohle und habe gute Homeoffice-Regelungen,
aber ich würde sogar auf bisschen Geld verzichten,
wenn die Homeoffice-Regelungen gut sind,
allerdings jetzt auch
nicht auf viel, da würde ich halt einfach nicht hingehen,
wenn es nicht passt,
also da muss schon grundsätzlich
die Kohle stimmen, Homeoffice stimmen,
das sind so meine zwei wichtigsten Punkte, Homeoffice
muss möglich sein, denn
Bahn fahren öfters
gerade, ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
ich wäre fast nach Würzburg gegangen in der Firma,
da hatte ich zwar auch fast dauerhaft Homeoffice,
aber,
da hätte ich ab und zu nach Würzburg fahren müssen,
und da hätte mich die Bahn sicherlich extremst
abgefuckt, Alter,
weil will ich Bayern, ja, da habe ich einen Tag mehr Urlaub,
das stimmt, das stimmt,
also, ich würde,
ich würde nicht Windows administrieren, egal
wie viel Geld, ne, das würde ich nicht sagen,
also, wenn mir einer extrem
viel Geld bezahlt dafür,
und dem klar ist, dass ich keine
Ahnung von Windows-Administration habe,
dann würde ich auch Windows administrieren,
Leute, ich bin da käuflich, ich habe kein Problem,
damit, aber, der müsste mir
dann wirklich schon enorm viel Geld bezahlen,
also, wenn da jetzt einer sagt,
Max, 300.000 Euro im Jahr,
350.000,
sag mal, 350.000 Euro
im Jahr, und du machst
Windows für mich, dann würde ich
Windows machen, kein Problem, also, wenn
mir einer dreimal mehr bietet,
ungefähr, knapp,
dreimal mehr bietet, als das, was ich jetzt
bekomme, dann
administriere ich auch Windows, habe ich kein Problem dafür,
würdest du First Level Support
für 150.000 Euro, nein,
auf gar keinen Fall, dafür nicht, dafür nicht,
du meinst die Kommentare unter
dem Video hier, die sind,
die sind, unter dem Video hier,
ne, ich, unter dem, wo ich eben war,
die sind Massive Cringe,
das ist, das ist wirklich, das ist wirklich schrecklich,
was wäre die wichtige
Homeoffice oder 4-Tage-Woche,
das ist schwierig,
das ist wirklich nicht so einfach,
die Frage, also,
jetzt mal Disclaimer, die Frage
wird sich bei mir gar nicht stellen, weil ich würde
einfach nirgendwo hingehen, wo es das eine und das andere
oder das andere nicht gibt,
aber gehen wir jetzt mal von aus,
das ist keine Option und ich müsste
mich dafür entscheiden, ja, aus irgendwelchen
Gründen müsste ich mich entscheiden
für einen Laden mit Homeoffice,
wo ich 5 Tage arbeiten müsste versus
einen Tag, 4 Tage und
kein Homeoffice, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
die, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich
sagen Homeoffice,
dann würde ich sagen Homeoffice ist mir lieber als 4-Tage-Woche,
allein schon das Gefahre,
was man sich erspart, ist ja auch
dann Zeit, was bringt denn eine 4-Tage-Woche,
wenn die andere 4 Tage
2 Stunden am Tag damit verbringst,
durch die Landschaft zu fahren, dann, dann lieber
5 Tage und
Homeoffice, aber
insgesamt würde ich zu keinem Laden
mehr gehen, der nicht beides
ermöglicht, ich, wie gesagt, ich arbeite
seit wann, seit 2000, 2012
oder so jetzt, 13 irgendwie,
ich weiß es gar nicht, Teilzeit,
ich kann mir das gar nicht mehr vorstellen,
Leute, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, wie ich
es damals geschafft habe,
aufzustehen so früh,
mit dem Bus
und der Bahn nach Frankfurt zu fahren,
das jeden Tag
und auch noch 5
Tage die Woche, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das
gemacht habe, es ist mir komplett unverständlich,
keine Ahnung, wie ich das überlebt, gut,
ich meine, lang habe ich das ja auch nicht gemacht,
lang habe ich das,
lang habe ich das nicht gemacht, ich meine,
ich mache es halt
ungefähr 2013,
4-Tage-Woche,
das heißt 2013,
dann habe ich quasi 5 Jahre,
5 Jahre richtig gearbeitet,
so mit 5-Tage-Woche
und dann habe ich 4-Tage-Woche gemacht,
easy life,
ja, also dann,
ich würde mich für den Homeoffice-Laden entscheiden,
wenn ich müsste, wie gesagt, ich würde
normalerweise gar nicht hingehen, aber wenn es jetzt wirklich
die Frage ist, das eine oder das andere, aus
irgendwelchen Gründen muss das sein, dann würde ich
den Homeoffice-Laden nehmen.
Was hältst du von der Idee, in Teilzeit zu gehen,
mit dem Ziel, in der Freizeit mehr zu lernen, um einen Job
zu machen?
Ganz ehrlich, unabhängig
davon, was dein Ziel ist
mit Teilzeit, wenn du dir das
leisten kannst, kann ich dir das
immer nur empfehlen, egal was du in deiner
Freizeit machen willst.
In deiner Freizeit was zu lernen, ist sicherlich
sehr sinnvoll, mache ich ja auch,
ja, also das, das meiste
an Technik-Know-How,
was neuere Sachen angeht,
habe ich tatsächlich aufgebaut,
unabhängig von der Arbeit.
Ich habe vieles von dem, dann
über die Jahre hinweg bei der Arbeit
gebraucht, ja, und konnte das dann auch in der Praxis
mir angucken, so, dass das in der Theorie
manchmal nicht so ganz damit übereinstimmt,
wie es dann wirklich ist.
Aber,
ich kann es dir nur empfehlen, 4-Tage-Woche ist das
Beste. Wisst ihr, bei der 4-Tage-Woche,
was da immer vergessen wird, ist,
man hat nicht nur
3 Tage am Stück frei,
oder, je nachdem, wie man den freien
Tag legt, sagen wir mal, ihr nehmt Montag oder Freitag,
ja, wisst ihr,
man hat nicht nur 3 Tage am Stück frei,
man muss auch einen Tag
weniger arbeiten.
Das muss einem da immer klar sein bei,
weil viele Leute denken sich im Kopf so,
ach, der eine Tag mehr, das macht's
doch auch nicht aus, und dafür auf Geld
verzichten, nein, nein, es ist nicht nur
der eine Tag. Es ist ein Tag
frei mehr, und ein Tag
arbeiten weniger, weil es ist ja nicht
so, dass die Woche danach 8
Tage hätte, und du hast 3 Tage
frei, nein, du hast dann 3 Tage
frei, 4 Tage arbeiten.
Es sind weiterhin 7 Tage, und dementsprechend
bist du auch deutlich weniger kaputt,
weil du ja nur 4 Tage, anstatt 5 Tage
arbeiten musstest. Und dann hast du am Stück
der nächste Schritt, 3 Tage
Woche, bedeutet schon wieder, dass du
4 Tage frei hast, und 3 Tage arbeiten musstest.
Es ist immer ein Tag mehr frei,
und ein Tag weniger arbeiten. Das heißt,
dieser eine Tag
bringt dadurch, dass er eben
ja, doppelte
Vorzüge hat, den Tag musst du
weniger arbeiten, und den Tag hast du mehr frei,
so viel
mehr Entspannung,
das ist aus meiner Sicht 20%
Gehalteinbuß mehr als wert,
durch Steuer ist es gar nicht ganz so viel,
weniger aber auch nicht bedeutend,
irgendwie, also
ungefähr plus minus, ja, bisschen
20%, und
euch geht's,
also, mir geht's
so viel besser mit 4 Tagen, als mit
5 Tagen, ich kann
das nur jedem empfehlen, der sich das irgendwie
finanziell leisten kann. Mal teils
davon nur nicht vergessen, dass man später weniger Rente
bekommt. Das ist richtig,
deswegen hab ich auch meine ETF-Stonks,
ich hab die
Altersvorsorge vom alten Arbeitgeber,
die ich ein paar Jahre gemacht hab, die Altersvorsorge
vom neuen Arbeitgeber,
meine ETF-Stonks,
plus noch ein paar andere Sachen,
und die 5,50 Euro,
die ich gesetzliche Rente krieg irgendwann,
die fallen dann hoffentlich gar nicht mehr, die sind
nice to have.
Wie werden die Urlaubstage eigentlich beeinflusst? Die werden
weniger, anteilmäßig, du kriegst 20% weniger
Urlaub. Ich hab
24 Tage, andere haben
30 Tage, glaub ich.
Oder?
Ja, passt doch. 20% von
30, genau.
Ich würde kein First Level Support für 150k
machen. Der MadMinister schreibt,
bei ihm steht dieses Jahr der nächste
Gehaltssprung an, ich bin
überlegt sogar abzu... Warum?
Weil ich aktuell genug verdiene und keine
große Veränderung, gute Arbeitsbedingungen.
Ach so!
Ja, nee, dann, also, wenn
mit dem Gehaltssprung so Sachen
verbunden sind, die man nicht machen möchte,
dann würde ich, okay, dann verstehe
ich das. Dann geht's ja aber nicht darum, dass du
einen Gehaltssprung, dass du quasi eine
Gehaltserhöhung ablehnst, es geht darum,
du lehnst ab, eine andere,
quasi deinen Job zu wechseln,
in eine andere Position, oder dass du da
auf eine andere Position wechseln willst,
lehnst du ab, was mit
einem Gehaltssprung verbunden wäre.
Also ist jetzt ja nicht so, dass einer
sagt, hier, du kriegst 20.000 Euro
mehr und du sagst, nö, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Es kommt einer zu dir und sagt, ey, du
musst Führungskraft werden, da kriegst du 20.000
Euro mehr und du sagst, nee, hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Also, das ist ja was anderes
und das kann ich voll und ganz verstehen,
da hätte ich auch
überhaupt gar keinen Bock drauf.
Auf der alten Arbeit, der Chef hat mir immer
versucht, die Karrieremöglichkeiten nahezulegen
und was es hier nicht noch alles gibt und was man Tolles
machen kann. Irgendwann hat er es auch gelernt,
ich bin niemand, der
Karriere im klassischen Sinn machen will,
mit Management-Shit oder
sonst was. Es ist aber einfach so, ich verstehe
auch gar nicht, warum das in so vielen Unternehmen noch
der Fall ist, es ist einfach so, es gibt
ganz wenige IT-Leute, die gute Manager sind,
dementsprechend gibt es auch
wenig Manager, die gute IT-Leute sind,
die sollen alle das machen, was sie gut können
und
dann ist wahrscheinlich allen am besten geholfen
bei. Dementsprechend
sind Unternehmen gut, die es
mittlerweile gecheckt haben, dass man
Leuten Karrieremöglichkeiten bieten muss,
außerhalb von Projektmanagement
und Führungsverantwortung.
Bei vielen Unternehmen hast du ja mittlerweile so
drei Karrieremöglichkeiten,
du hast einmal so Personal-
Führungsverantwortung, Personalverantwortung,
Teamleiter und
der klassische Karriereweg,
den viele früher auch so als einziges
hatten, gibt es immer noch. Dann
hast du was Richtung Projekte und Projektmanagement,
das ist der zweite Karriereweg, den es
in vielen Unternehmen gibt und der dritte ist
tatsächlich für die ganzen Techniker und
Programmierer, irgendwelche
fachlichen Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten.
Vom Anwendungsentwickler
zum Senior-Anwendungsentwickler,
zum Architekt,
zu solchen Geschichten.
Und das finde ich sinnvoll, weil
dann kann man weiterhin das machen, was
man gut kann, wo man Bock drauf hat
und man hat trotzdem
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten und man muss sich
nicht mit diesem Blödsinn hier auseinandersetzen.
Das ist einfach für die meisten nichts.
Die meisten können es auch nicht.
Man muss einfach immer
gucken, wo die Stärken sind.
Würdest du Windows-Systeme für die IHK
administrieren? Ja,
für sehr viel Geld schon.
Das ist
das Problem.
Es steigt natürlich immer mehr,
was es sein muss dafür.
Bei dir ist nichts mehr mit Homeoffice,
dann hat er Pech und muss damit rechnen,
dass ihm die Leute wegrennen.
Du kannst es gerade in der IT, kannst du dir das
heutzutage gar nicht mehr so sehr aussuchen,
wie sich das viele Leute vorstellen.
So nach dem Motto, ja, wir sind ja,
ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, viele Unternehmen
sind da noch ein bisschen im letzten Jahrtausend
fast schon stecken geblieben.
Das sieht man auch an den Stellenanzeigen.
Ihr kennt doch die üblichen Stellenanzeigen.
Wir sind Firma XY.
Marktführer im Bereich sowieso.
Das schreiben ja alle.
Modernes, dynamisches Team,
bla bla bla. Wir freuen uns auf ihre aussagekräftige
Bewerbung. Wo du dir dann denkst, okay,
schön, dass ihr euch darauf freut, aber ich
bewerbe mich nicht bei euch.
Weil nichts
von der Anzeige spricht mich an.
Und die haben es doch gar nicht gecheckt,
dass man sich da vielleicht auch ein bisschen Mühe geben muss.
Ja, und dementsprechend können sich
viele Unternehmen heute auch einfach gar nicht leisten,
so
wenig von dem zu machen,
was Leute sich wünschen, weil dann
gehen schlicht und ergreifend keine mehr hin.
Und wenn keiner mehr hingeht,
hast du das Problem, dass das auch irgendwann
die Leute checken, die dort sind
und dass da nicht nur keiner mehr Neues hingeht,
sondern die Leute, die da sind,
auch langsam mit der Zeit abwandern.
Und dann ist die Kacke am Dampfen dort.
Ja.
Wie kam es dazu, vier Tage
Woche zu arbeiten? Da habe ich einen sehr ausführlichen
Video auf YouTube gemacht.
Vier Tage Woche.
Warum die vier Tage?
Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es...
Guck mal, hier.
Teilzeitarbeiten, die beste Entscheidung
und warum die vier Tage Woche besser ist.
So.
Habe ich auf YouTube gemacht, das kannst du dir
angucken. Hallo Leute, hier ist der
Max und Jap. Und das kannst
du dir angucken.
Da rede ich, da rede ich ein bisschen ausführlicher
drüber. Aber kurz und
knapp, warum ich vier Tage Woche mache.
Weil ich es kann.
Das ist, glaube ich, die beste
Erklärung, die es da gibt.
Weil es geht.
Weil es finanziell
kein Problem ist.
Und der ursprüngliche Gedanke,
der ursprüngliche Gedanke war ja,
da habe ich einen Tag mehr, mich um YouTube und
Twitch und sowas zu kümmern.
Ist auch weiterhin der Fall.
Aber hauptsächlich
geht es mir mittlerweile um
das deutlich entspanntere Leben
mit vier Tage arbeiten, drei Tage frei.
Und aus aktuellen Gesichtspunkten
mache ich es eigentlich nur noch, weil ich es kann.
Und ich sehe es auch nicht
mehr einig zu machen.
Das gibt einige Sachen,
die keinen Spaß
mehr machen. Also, ich bin ja auch jemand,
der gerne so Microcontroller bastelt,
programmiert, lötet und sowas.
Als Job würde ich das auch nicht machen wollen.
Das stimmt.
Wie gesagt, hast 20%
weniger Urlaub. Ich habe 24 Urlaubstage
anstatt 30.
Ähm, doch.
Die müssen
sogar, also die müssen das
nicht in die Stellenanzeige reinschreiben.
Aber wenn du sagst,
ich meine, das kann sein, dass das alles erst ab einer gewissen
Betriebsgröße gilt,
was ich jetzt sage.
Aber normalerweise ist es so,
wenn du Vollzeit wo arbeitest und sagst
jetzt, hallo Chef,
ich möchte Teilzeit arbeiten.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es in einem Fünf-Mann-Betrieb
was anderes ist. Ja, bei einem größeren Unternehmen ist das so.
Dann sind die dazu verpflichtet,
dir das zu ermöglichen.
Es sei denn, es sprechen
dringende betriebliche Gründe
dagegen, dass es jetzt nicht möglich ist.
Aber im gleichen Zug
müssen die diese Gründe
abstellen.
Also, es ist gar nicht so einfach,
Teilzeitarbeit
zu verbieten. Das Ding ist halt,
realistisch gesehen
kannst du natürlich sagen, also
kannst du sagen, ich würde gerne Teilzeit arbeiten.
Dein Chef sagt, nein, will ich nicht.
Dann sagst du doch rechtlich gesehen,
dann kündigt dich dein Chef halt.
Fristgerecht.
Das kann dir dann natürlich passieren,
wenn es so ganz verhärtete
Fronten sind. Ja, und das
ein kleinerer Laden ist, wo es auch
keinen Betriebsrat oder irgendwelche Regelungen
zu sowas gibt. Aber in größeren
Unternehmen ist das meistens kein Problem.
Oder ab 15 Mitarbeiter. Ja, ich weiß
es nicht, aber der Chat ist wieder
high IQ, der Chat hat wieder Prime subscribt.
Die wissen Bescheid.
Machst du eigentlich vier Tage mal sieben Stunden
oder acht Stunden, also
was? Nee.
Mach ich nicht. Ich arbeite 30 Stunden
die Woche.
Ungefähr. Ich glaub, bisschen mehr. 30,5
oder sowas.
Und vier Tage.
Achso, vier Tage, acht Stunden.
Ja.
Siebeneinhalb oder sowas
sind es, glaube ich. Übrigens, ich finde
die Diskussionen richtig nice, die aktuell
stattfinden. Habt ihr gelesen, ein paar Banken
in Frankfurt, ich weiß, war es sogar die Commerzbank?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Die überlegen, ob sie die Vier-Tage-Woche einführen sollen.
Allerdings dann
mit
wie war das?
Nicht exakt der gleichen
Arbeitszeit, aber auch nicht mit
einem Tag weniger Arbeitszeit. Ich glaube
50% weniger Arbeitszeit.
Also quasi
anstatt 40 Stunden
nur 35, aber
die dann an vier Tagen, sowas.
Also quasi jeden Tag eine Stunde mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Commerzbank war,
irgendwelche Banken in Frankfurt. Hab ich letztens
einen Newsartikel drüber gelesen. Wenn ich
mir das vorgestellt habe,
habe ich mir gedacht,
das wäre super geil, wenn sie das bei mir
in der Versicherung auch einführen.
Weil das bedeutet, für mich gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten.
Es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder, die machen das
und ich bekomme automatisch
mehr Geld, weil ich bin ja dann schon
quasi auf dem
kleineren
Arbeitspensum. Da kriege ich einfach
keine Ahnung, 15% mehr Geld
oder sowas. Soll mir auch recht sein.
Wenn es das nicht gibt, dann sage ich ja
ok, dann gleiche Kohle, aber dann arbeite ich nur drei Tage.
Also ich bin
sofort dabei, wenn die sowas machen wollen.
Das Ding ist halt nur, wenn
die mit sowas anfangen,
ich denke mir, es ist halt so,
die haben jetzt schon Probleme, Leute zu finden.
Und wenn du jetzt noch das ganze reduzierst,
dann brauchst du ja im Endeffekt
quasi so für vier Leute
einen neuen.
Alle vier Leute einen neuen. Wisst ihr?
Dass man wieder so auf die gleiche Arbeit kommt,
die gepackt wird.
Weil das ja auch immer fraglich ist,
es gibt ja Untersuchungen, die sagen, ey Leute,
die vier Tage arbeiten und so und so lang,
da ist gar kein wirklicher
Arbeitsleistungsunterschied
zu sehen versus
fünf Tage.
Dadurch wirst du attraktiver für Bewerber.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage,
ich weiß, das habe ich mir auch so gedacht,
das ist halt die Frage, ob dort
dann die Schwelle überschritten wird,
dass
du musst mehr einstellen,
quasi, also die mehr Bewerber
diesen Vorteil überwiegt,
dass du mehr Leute einstellst,
dass quasi überdurchschnittlich mehr Leute
bewerben, als
du an neuen Stellen brauchst.
Weiß ich nicht, ob da die Rechnung aufgeht,
falls sie damit planen,
aber insgesamt
gehe ich von aus,
ist das die Zukunft.
Das gibt es bei uns auch,
das gibt es bei uns auch, aber
bei mir ist es so, ich habe montags fest frei.
Das ist auch von der Zeiterfassung
gut, bei mir steht einfach in der Zeiterfassung,
0 Sollstunden montags.
Ja, so Personalführungsverantwortung
hätte ich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ja, ja, so würde ich es ungefähr rechnen.
Lieber Menschen als Windows Server.
Oh, hättest du das als Frage formuliert, hätte ich nicht gewusst,
was ich darauf antworten soll.
Chat, was wäre euch lieber?
Täglich mit Menschen arbeiten
oder Windows Server administrieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich weniger
machen würde.
Das ist ja Horror, beides.
Lieber Windows?
Wirklich?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich mich auch für Windows entscheiden,
in dem Fall, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte.
So mit random Menschen jeden Tag.
Aber Windows Server ist halt auch ganz, ganz
großer Bullshit.
Den Windows Server nutzen, um Menschen zu kompilieren.
Ja, alles klar.
Ey, mein Nasen juckt, Alter.
Ihr hattet recht, Leute.
Ihr hattet recht.
Ich kann heute.
Sag bloß, ich hab mich irgendwo angesteckt, ey.
Ragequit.
So, ich hab jetzt mal die Nase geputzt.
Ich hoffe ja nicht, dass ich mich irgendwo angesteckt habe.
Das muss echt nicht sein.
Nächste Welle kommt.
Oh, das brauch ich.
Ey, Corona will ich auf gar keinen Fall noch machen.
Corona war richtig kacke.
Ich war drei Wochen im Arsch.
Ich hab euch das ja erzählt.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Das hab ich noch nicht erlebt.
Es wäre auch sehr weird, wenn man sagt,
wir haben eine Kantine,
aber du darfst erst nach der Probezeit in die Kantine.
Oder
wir haben
einen
Parkplatz,
aber da darfst du erst nach der Probezeit parken.
Das ist weird.
Da würde ich mir Gedanken machen, was ist das für ein Laden.
Auf der anderen Seite, in manchen Fällen
könnte ich mir vielleicht sogar vorstellen,
dass das Sinn macht.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Also, das hab ich noch nicht erlebt,
aber man kann es mir jetzt nicht so wirklich ausmalen.
Das Ja des Linux-Desktops.
Ja, endlich.
Wie wäre es mit anderen Menschen beibringen,
wie man Windows-Server administriert?
NO GOD!
NO GOD, PLEASE NO!
NO!
Also mal davon abgesehen, dass ich das nicht kann.
Und ich möchte aber auch nicht,
dass mir jemand beibringt,
wie man Windows-Server administriert.
Es gibt so zwei Sachen, die mag ich nicht.
Also,
anderen mit
random Leuten
zusammen irgendwas machen, die ich nicht kenne
und Windows-Server administriert.
Es gibt noch mehr Sachen, die ich nicht mag,
aber das sind zwei Sachen, die mag ich nicht.
Ja, weiß man ja meist nicht.
Also, ich weiß wenigstens, woher ich mein Corona hatte.
Ich war damals in Frankfurt
vor eineinhalb Jahren
oder wann das war, auf einem Iron...
Warum sagen wir in Deutschland
eigentlich Iron Maiden?
Die Engländer sagen Iron.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum das R
weggelassen wird, aber egal,
wir sind ja hier. Dieser Chat ist jetzt
deutsch. Ich war auf einem Iron Maiden
Konzert
im Frankfurter Stadion
und da haben so viele
Leute rumgeschrien
und dementsprechend sind da wahrscheinlich auch die
Coronaviren rumgeflogen, wie sonst was.
Ich hab schon gleich, Tag später
gemerkt, du kriegst das früher
oder später auch. Musst gar nicht probieren,
dran vorbeizukommen. Ich mein, wenn ihr es
schafft, alles gut.
Aber ich...
Früher, du fängst dir das
einmal falsch eingeatmet an der falschen Stelle
und zack, hast es.
Padoherli, dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog, 34 Monate.
Massive.
Excellent, excellent.
Ah ja, okay. Ja.
Ich mein, nachdem das nicht der einzige Grund ist,
warum er dort arbeitet,
glaub ich nicht, dass es so wild
ist, oder?
Vielleicht ist das auch was, was
langfristig abgeschlossen werden müsste.
Muss, je nachdem, was da dahinter steckt.
Und dementsprechend, wenn die Leute potenziell
dann nach sechs Monaten wieder weg sind, ist es halt
problematisch. Ja, vielleicht hast du
doch Glück und
schrammst noch dran vorbei an Corona.
Ich will's auf jeden Fall nicht
noch ein zweites Mal haben. Das war
richtig kacke.
Ich hatte da immer noch zwei, also
eine Woche war so richtig, also eineinhalb Wochen war so richtig
scheiße. Und die
nächste, nächsten zwei Wochen, eineinhalb,
zwei, sag mal zwei Wochen, war ich
so kaputt.
Chat, erzählt mal.
Also für alle, die auch schon
die Ehre hatten.
Ich sag euch mal, wie das bei mir war.
Es ging dann wieder halbwegs gut, ich konnt wieder
aus dem Bett raus und sonst wie.
Und dann bin ich meine normale
Runde hier um den Main, ist
ungefähr siebeneinhalb Kilometer.
Und ich bin angefangen, die Runde zu laufen.
Normalerweise ist das überhaupt kein Problem.
Wenn man langsam läuft, auch kein Problem.
Und ich bin losgelaufen,
hier lang über die Brücke
und dann hab ich mir gedacht, ich kann nicht
mehr. Da musste ich mich hinsetzen.
Ich musste mich ernsthaft
hinsetzen auf meiner normalen Runde.
Mir ist zum ersten Mal aufgefallen,
wie viele Bänke da eigentlich stehen.
Ich musste mich hinsetzen.
Und dann bin ich umgedreht.
Dann hab ich da zehn Minuten gehockt. Dann bin ich umgedreht.
Dann musste ich mich nochmal hinsetzen. Ich war richtig
im Arsch, ja. Ich war richtig im Arsch.
Das auch.
Das hab ich auch gemerkt.
Also,
es gibt ja Leute, die sagen,
man schmeckt
nichts mehr. Ich hab schon noch
Sachen geschmeckt. Das war, wie du
das beschreibst hier,
ich hab die Sachen so anders geschmeckt.
Das war ganz komisch. Nicht nur anders
geschmeckt,
sondern, ja dafür ging's
aber relativ schnell wieder weg.
Alt sein geht meistens nicht wieder weg.
Und,
Geschmacks-
und Geruchssinn war anders.
Ich war fast am Anfang sogar schon ein bisschen
schlecht dadurch, weil's total fremd
war
mir in meiner eigenen Wohnung,
in meinem eigenen Schlafzimmer dadurch.
Das war ganz, ganz
weird. Und wisst ihr, was das einzige
war? Ich hab überhaupt keinen
Appetit, überhaupt keinen Hunger.
Und ihr wisst, da muss schon was Schlimmes mit mir
sein, wenn ich nix fressen kann.
Und ich hatte überhaupt keinen Appetit,
keinen Hunger. Ich hab da nur rumgegammelt.
Und wisst ihr, was das
einzige, was das einzige war, was ich essen konnte
und was auch noch so ungefähr
so geschmeckt hat, wie
normal? Ich hatte,
ich hatte so aus dem Lidl so Hefezopf,
so Gebäckzeug.
Und das hab ich
geschnitten mit Lachs.
Nein,
nicht Lachs, nicht Nudeln mit Lachs.
Aber nur,
ich hab heute, ich hab heute, stellt euch mal vor, ich hab
heute keine Nudeln mit Lachs gegessen.
Ich hab heute Nudeln mit, äh, ich hab heute Nudeln mit
Reis, Alter. Nein, ich hab heute Lachs
mit Reis gegessen, tatsächlich. Nicht,
nicht Lachs mit Nudeln, Lachs mit Reis.
Ja, ich hab, ich hab
so Hefe, Hefezopf,
sowas hatte ich vom Lidl
da, so ein Ding.
Und nachdem ich drei Tage
fast nix gegessen hab, äh, mit,
mit oder, oder fast vier Tage, glaub
ich anders sogar, während Corona fast
nix gegessen hab, dann hab ich diesen
Hefe, da hab ich den Hefezopf rausgeholt aus,
aus dem Kühlschrank, hab Quark
drauf geschmiert und gefühlt ne halbe,
halbe Flasche Honig drüber
geschüttet und hab das gefressen.
Und das hat geschmeckt,
süß, das, das, das hab ich noch
geschmeckt. Das war das einzige, was normal
geschmeckt hat und was leicht
verdaulich ist und super viele Kalorien hat, wenn ich's
in der, ich hab da, ich hab quasi dann
zwei Tage lang von, ähm,
ich hatte glücklicherweise nicht nur, nein,
von Hefezopf, Quark
und massig Honig draufgelebt,
bis es mir wieder besser ging.
Das war mein, mein Corona-Essen.
Bist du wieder vollkommen recovered?
Ja, kein Problem. Ich bin mehr
als recovered.
Also wenn's, wenn's danach geht, müsste
man den Keck Alu-Leuten glauben, so nach dem
Motto, äh, alles überhaupt
kein Problem. Also ich bin mehr als
recovered von Corona. Ich bin
improved. Aber nicht durch Corona,
sondern weil ich mich mittlerweile
mehr bewege und auch
mehr Sport mache, so von Rennen und Fahrrad
fahren und generell täglich, täglich
laufen. Nicht, nicht täglich joggen, täglich
laufen, ja. Eineinhalb
Stunden, eineinhalb Stunden, also eineinhalb
Stunden jeden Tag laufen. Plus
jeden zweiten Tag joggen oder alternativ
noch einen Tag Pause und dafür dann
Fahrrad fahren. Und jetzt bin ich improved
dadurch. Das hat aber
nichts mit Corona zu tun.
Wo wir grad dabei sind, ich muss mal gucken, ob's
mal ein Fahrrad wieder lieferbar gibt.
Weil ich brauch ja, ich
brauch ja wieder ein neues Fahrrad.
Wie sieht's denn hier aus? Äh,
Größe aus,
ausverkauft, okay, und in grün?
In grün?
Ausverkauft? In blau? Fuck,
meine
Mein Fahrrad gibt's nicht mehr.
Shit, mal gucken, ob ich jemals
wieder ein ordentliches Fahrrad, ja gut, gibt ja noch
mehr Hersteller. Richtig, richtig.
Ich hab, ich hab das neue Mindset,
Grindset Mindset, das neue High Performer
Mindset, ja. Wisst ihr, was
echt motivierend ist?
Ich hab ja das alles per Fitness Tracker und
so, äh, drinne. Und ich guck
mir regelmäßig so die, die, die Grafiken
an dazu.
Es ist einfach unglaublich motivierend,
wenn es Stonks,
Grafen gibt.
So blöd es klingt, wenn, wenn,
wenn grüne Pfeile nach oben
gehen, ist das motivierend.
Mal bei Rose angefragt
für ein Placement. Ich glaube, da bin ich
der falsche Channel für.
Ich mach IT Zeug und keinerlei
Sportcontent. Ich mein, man
könnte grade aus dem Gesichtspunkt vielleicht
sagen, okay, Rose könnte sich bei
mir vielleicht eine komplett neue
Schicht an Käufern erschließen.
Ich mein, dann, ich, ey,
ich mein, nen Fahrrad,
also so, wenn es das wirklich auch
das Fahrrad ist, so wie ich das haben will,
äh, da würde ich tatsächlich auch ein ausgedehntes
Sponsoring mit mir reden lassen
zu, ja. Würde ich machen.
Ich glaube, das würde auch gar nicht so schlecht ankommen.
Aber das, das nächste Ding ist,
ich hätte ja lieber eine 1x12 Schaltung.
Die gibt's grad noch nicht. Elektronisch.
Lachs mit Reis,
was bei dir falsch? Ja, es muss mal was anderes
sein. Das Fahrrad mit dem
Anime Paint Shop, nee, das war
Canyon, oder?
Hup, what the fuck,
Ken? Ja?
Wo ist es denn?
Ho-kyo Edition?
Was da?
Genau. Das wäre das
hier. Nee,
das ist, das ist mir, also das, also,
ich finde, das sieht
mega nice aus, obwohl ich jetzt nicht so der
Ultra-Weep bin.
Ich find, das sieht mega nice aus.
Das Fahrrad würde ich mir aber nicht holen,
weil es deutlich für mich zu sportliche
Sitzposition hat.
Rose kann, selbst Rose
könnte das gar nicht machen,
weil es die Schaltung noch nicht gibt.
Shimano hat
aktuell bloß eine 1x12 Schaltung,
mechanisch,
und ich hätte gerne eine elektronische
1x12 Schaltung, die gibt's doch nicht.
Und auf
SRAM habe ich aus anderen Gründen keinen Bock, zum Beispiel,
weil die oben keine Buttons haben. Das finde ich sehr nice,
dass du bei Shimano oben Buttons hast,
wo du dein Fahrradcomputer steuern kannst am Lenker,
ohne dass du drauf touchen musst oder drauf
dran greifen musst. Ja,
also,
ich finde optisch sieht das mega cool aus,
aber das Fahrrad wäre
vom,
von der Ergonomie her nix für mich.
Weiß ich nicht,
keine Ahnung. Musik,
Pog. Kennt ihr das?
Hm.
Wenn ihr manchmal Probleme habt zu
pennen, kommt ja ab und zu mal vor,
es ist nicht, als hätte ich Schlafstörungen oder sowas.
Ja, aber manchmal hast du irgendwie, machst
dir Gedanken oder denkst du über was nach,
oder hast, hast, hast zu viel
äh, Noobs gebasht, bevor
du ins Bett gehst und bist noch aufgeregt,
keine Ahnung. Ja, manchmal kann man nicht richtig
pennen und da legt man so
im Bett und es klappt nix und
da macht man sich ein YouTube-Video an und
dann, anstatt dabei einzupennen,
hört man eher beim YouTube-Video zu und kann
nicht richtig pennen. Zumindest,
was bei mir oft hilft,
ist, wenn ich mir
Sachen mit Sounds anmache,
die ich
früher,
quasi, gehört hab so.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir
Mario 64 Let's Play anmache
oder sowas, einfach die
Sounds von dem Game
im Hintergrund, die beruhigen
mich, da penne ich fast
instant ein. Oder auch irgendwelche
Super Nintendo Games oder sowas.
Wenn es was ist, wo ich irgendwie ne
Erinnerung im Kopf hab, so
wie ich früher im Wohnzimmer gesessen hab und gespielt
hab oder so, sobald ich das anmach
und da so ein bisschen dabei zuhöre,
da ratze ich direkt weg.
Mir hilft alles komplett dunkel, keine Medien,
kein Licht, nichts.
Ja, so, genau sowas meine ich.
Sowas meine ich im Prinzip, ja.
Bei dir könnte es das sein, bei mir ist es
vielleicht irgendwelche Super Nintendo Games
Sounds oder so. Also, das
war früher
bei mir ähnlich.
Das Problem ist nur, ich hab's mir
komplett versaut, seit ich
angefangen hab, Streaming
und YouTube-Videos im Bett
zu gucken.
Seitdem kann ich nicht mehr pennen, ohne dass
was läuft. Ich hab mehr oder weniger
die gesamte Nacht irgendwas laufen mittlerweile.
Sei es nur irgendwelche
Chill-Music-Listen
oder irgendwelche
News
aus dem Weltall,
das Universum,
eineinhalb Stunden Doku oder sowas.
Was ich auch mir gerne
angucke sind Mathe-Vorlesungen
von der Uni.
Also angucke ist
falsch, falsches, falsches
Wort, ja.
Unterbewusst anhören und
dabei pennen. Ich glaube ich bin der Einzige,
der bei Mathe-Vorlesungen so gut schlafen
kann, Alter.
Also ich kann
meistens auch wie ein Stein
pennen, ja. Aber manchmal
geht's nicht, selten. Aber meistens bin ich
instant weg.
Und schlaf dann auch gut.
Es ist schon 10, richtig, richtig. Aber
heute hab ich ein bisschen länger Zeit.
Ja, ich kann das nicht mehr, ich kann das nicht mehr.
Und ich merkt, ganz, ganz weird,
eigentlich würde man's umgedreht vermuten,
wenn's zu leise
ist im Schlafzimmer, dann träum ich
komische Sachen.
So richtig weirden Shit.
Ich hab letztens geträumt, das ist ganz abgedrehtes
Zeug, ja.
Als es meiner Katze nicht gut ging,
hab ich, habt ihr ja mitbekommen,
als es meiner Katze nicht gut ging,
also, wo ich jetzt,
eines der ersten Sachen, wo ich mitbekommen hab,
dass es meiner Katze nicht gut ging,
die Katze hat zu hohen Blutdruck gehabt,
ist, und das äußert sich bei Katzen
oftmals, dass die so kleine
Blutungen im Auge haben.
An der Seite, ganz klein sieht man kaum.
Das wird bei Katzen oft durch zu hohen
Blutdruck verursacht.
Und
ich weiß noch, in einer Nacht,
nachdem das war, ich mein, macht man sich natürlich
Gedanken um seine Katz und sowas,
und
irgendwann hatte ich mal nachts
keine Musik und nix laufen,
und da weiß ich noch, da hab ich geträumt,
dass meine Katze,
die Katze vor mir gestanden hat,
und ihr die Augen geplatzt sind.
Und da hatte ich,
übelst bin ich, bin ich dann
zu mir gekommen und war übelst fertig, ey.
Ja, richtig MonkaS,
Mann. Da hab ich auch gedacht,
boah, Alter, Max, was los?
Und dann, dann bin ich aufgewacht und hab festgestellt,
es ist einfach nur dunkel
und leise. Und danach hab ich
mir ein bisschen Chill-Musik auf dem Handy
angemacht und hab danach super geschlafen,
ohne irgendeinen Shit zu träumen.
Also, ich brauch Hintergrundgeräusche,
sonst träum ich komisches Zeug.
Also, man träum
teilweise schon echt abartigen
Kram so. Regengeräusche,
ja. Das hab ich auch mal gemacht,
ähm, da gibt's dann so zehn
Stunden tropischer, tropischer
Regen. Ich hatte mal
vor ner ganzen Weile, wo
wo ich mich noch nicht so
viel bewegt hab, wo ich öfters
mal so Verspannungen und Rückenprobleme hatte,
da hatte ich mal zwei,
drei Wochen so ein Piepsgeräusch im Ohr.
Das kam so von Nackenmuskelverspannung
und sowas.
Und das hat mich so, das hat mich so
genervt. Und damit ich das
quasi nicht hören musste, hab ich
mir auf dem Handy tropische Regenfälle
angemacht, nebers Ohr gelegt, auf der
rechten oder linken, ich weiß gar nicht, es war,
es war rechts.
Neber, nebers Ohr gelegt.
Und das, dieses, dieses
Rauschen vom Regen, das war das einzige, wo ich
wie man das, wie das nachts nicht gestört hat.
Also, es hat, ein paar Sachen
hab ich schon gelernt dadurch, dass ich nachts
beim Schlafen Mathevorlesungen höre, aber viel
nicht. Oh je.
War das gut oder schlecht?
Übrigens ein sehr cutes Emote.
Und wie war das so?
War das eher, war das eher gut oder schlecht?
Ja, gibt Leute, die
pennen da auch vor Ort.
Wie importierst du deine Dot-Files eigentlich?
Das mach ich damit. Also, erst einmal
meine Dot-Files
gibt es auf Shithub
hier.
Und die kann man pushen, ist schon ein Jahr her.
Und die verwalte ich mit
Chess-moi.
Ohne jetzt zu wissen, ob man das
so ausspricht.
Schätz-moi. Das ist Pock-Tool, ja.
Du hast mal Enterprise
Brücken-Ambiente ausprobiert.
Was darf ich mal unter Enterprise, also Brücken-
Ambiente, da stell ich mir nichts Gutes
drunter vor. So Frankfurt
der S-Bahn-Brücke oder so. Aber was sind
Enterprise-Brücken? Ach, ach.
Star Trek.
Jetzt verstehe
ich das.
So Raumschiff, Raumschiff
Brücken-Ambiente.
Ach, das.
Okay.
Ja, das ist ja meistens auch so weißes,
weißes, dumpfes Rauschen so.
Mir fällt gerade auf, Chat.
Morgen ist ja Sonntag.
Da machen wir ja schon direkt wieder
Aufwachen-Stream morgen früh.
Was ist da los? Das heißt, ich gehe
jetzt offline,
penne und dann wird wieder gestreamt.
Gut, dass ich das Video für morgen schon hochgeladen
habe. Ich muss es nur noch freischalten.
Kannst du die i3-Config zeigen?
Ich will mir die CPU-Anzeige kopieren.
Du gehst auf GitHub in meinen
.files-Ordner.
Dann gehst du auf
.config
i3-config
und dann ist es
höchstwahrscheinlich
das hier.
Wird vielleicht nicht
eins zu eins bei dir so funktionieren wegen
dem Kram hier drin, dann kannst du aber rausschmeißen.
Die CPU-Anzeige kommt ja
von dem Statusbar-Plugin.
Das ist das hier.
Wo ist es denn hier?
CPU-Layout.
Das da ist es, glaube ich.
Das ist übrigens
mega nice, die CPU-Anzeige.
Wenn man mal ein bisschen CPU-Last
verursacht, hier guckt, dann seht ihr,
dass es acht verschiedene Cores
oder wie viele Cores haben wir? Acht, glaube ich.
Acht verschiedene Cores und
du siehst halt, wie die einzelnen
Cores ausgelastet sind. Das ist so ein richtiges
so ein richtiges Mini-
Taskmanager kann man nicht sagen,
aber so richtig Mini-Anzeige,
die
sich halt sehr
gut widerspiegelt, wo hier was
ausgelastet ist. Finde ich gut.
Fällt mir. Na gut, deswegen
habe ich es vielleicht ja auch.
Histogramm.
Ah ja, Frankfurt. Wenn ich an
Brücke denke, denke ich Frankfurt der S-Bahn-Brücke
oder sowas. Was sind die
drei Zahlen davor? Das ist Load.
Load unter Linux ist
immer Load.
Oh fuck, jetzt nicht, dass ich Mist erzähle.
Load ist immer eine Minute, fünf Minuten.
Nee.
Fünf. Nee, was ist, wie ist
die Anzeige von Load?
30 Sekunden, eine Minute,
fünf Minuten oder fünf Sekunden, eine
Minute, fünf Minuten oder
1, 3, 50?
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ja, das ist
die Load über eine gewisse Zeit.
Also aktuell habe ich eine relativ
hohe Load gehabt, kurzzeitig,
weil ich habe, das siehst du ja, wenn ich
hier mal Load verursache,
dann geht die kurzzeitige Load
hoch, aber die Load über die
letzten drei und 15 Minuten
geht halt kaum hoch, weil
ist halt nicht viel, wenn ich das
wieder ausmache. Dementsprechend,
wenn es mal lange Zeit hoch war, geht die auch langsam
mal wieder runter. 1, 5, 15
sind es? Ja, was denn? Jetzt habe ich drei Sachen
zur Auswahl.
Chat geben. Kennst du eine gute
Seite um Gehaltsdurchschnitte für
ID-Jobs anzeigen, am besten mit Kriterien?
Da gibt es ein paar, aber ich habe
da noch keine gefunden, wo ich sagen würde, oh ja,
das, da würde ich mich
drauf verlassen. Was ich immer
gut finde ist, andere
Leute fragen, wie es bei ihnen
so ist. Am besten
halt, sagen wir mal, ähnliche
Region, ähnlicher Job.
Zum Beispiel meinen Twitch-Chat könntest du fragen.
Wie es da aussieht.
Also, wir haben hier
öfters mal das Thema Einstiegsgehalt.
Einstiegsgehalt,
je nachdem, was es ist, kann ich auch nicht
viel zu sagen. Das einzige, was ich den Leuten dann immer
erzählen kann ist, mein
Einstiegsgehalt hochgerechnet,
wenn du da mal Inflation und alles mit einrechnest,
mein Einstiegsgehalt
hochgerechnet auf 2024
und das sind glaube
ich
46.000 Euro. Also damals
waren es 33.500.
Ich denke, das ist gerade für Frankfurt
und Umgebung eine ganz gute Hausnummer.
Ja, das
ist so, aber das machen wir hier
nicht, sondern wir reden hier ganz
normal drüber. Hier ist es ja auch
ein bisschen anonym, deswegen ist das kein Problem.
Außer
dein Nickname auf Twitch ist
zufälligerweise dein Real Name und jeder auf der Arbeit
weiß, dass du es bist, kann man hier alles
erzählen. Natürlich ist es jetzt ja auch so ein Ding,
manche Leute schreiben hier sicherlich auch viel Blödsinn.
Aber so im Großen und Ganzen
würde ich sagen, ist der
Twitch-Chat doch schon eine
verhältnismäßig
gute Quelle,
dass ich das mal sag.
Also mein Twitch-Chat.
Weil nur mein Twitch-Chat ist high IQ
genug, das zu checken.
Jeder kennt mich auf der Arbeit nur an diesem Namen.
Ja, dachte ich mir. Superschurke ist auch eindeutig
Real Name.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, was der Vor- und
Nachname ist. Guck mal, ob es
neue Package-Updates gibt.
Wir haben ja 8 Linux.
By the way.
32k für 48 Stunden.
In welchem Bereich? Also
für was?
Also 32k ist in der Tat enorm wenig.
Gerade in Berlin,
wo wahrscheinlich mit 32k
du 100% dafür aufwenden musst,
von dem, was die dir aufs Konto
überweisen, dass du überhaupt deine Wohnung bezahlen kannst.
Oh, das ist doch nice.
Ich habe jetzt Februar Zwischenprüfung.
Physik. Quatsch. Zwischenprüfung.
Easy. Hast du schon alte Prüfungen
gemacht? Ready.
Du musst alte Prüfungen machen.
Wenn du noch keine alten Prüfungen gemacht hast,
dann hast du zu Recht Schiss davor.
Wenn du schon alte Prüfungen gemacht hast
und die gut laufen, musst du keinen Schiss davor haben.
Hast du denn schon alte Prüfungen gemacht?
PostChamp?
Ich PostChamp jetzt, bis er antwortet.
Nicht unter Druck gesetzt fühlen?
Habe ich.
Genau deswegen hast du aber...
Wieso schneidest du nicht gut ab bei den alten Prüfungen?
Dann gibt es einfach einen
weiteren Trick. Noch mehr alte Prüfungen
machen, bis man gut abschneidet.
Ich sage dir jetzt mal ehrlich, wie es ist.
Die IHK Prüfung.
Wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen zwei
Leuten.
Einer, der die Ausbildung gemacht hat,
dreieinhalb bis drei Jahre
und sich richtig Mühe gegeben hat,
richtig Ahnung hat.
Ohne spezielle Vorbereitung auf die Prüfung.
Versus jemand,
der die Ausbildung nicht gemacht hat
und sich einfach zwei Monate
mit täglich Prüfungslernen vorbereitet.
Also ich würde auf den Typ
wetten, der zwei Monate am Stück
Prüfung gemacht hat und eigentlich gar keinen Plan hat.
Wer die bessere Abschlussprüfung schreibt.
Das heißt,
es geht bei der Abschlussprüfung und bei der
Zwischenprüfung weniger darum, dass du
ein guter Fisi bist
und fachliche Ahnung hast.
Sondern es geht darum, dass du IHK
Deutsch verstehst und
das hinschreibst, was die IHK wissen will.
Egal wie viel
oder wie wenig das mit deinem täglichen
Arbeitsablauf, mit deinen täglichen Aufgaben
mit der Realität an sich zu tun hat.
Du musst IHK Prüfung
lernen und IHK
Prüfungsmäßig halt
die Dinger beantworten, so wie die das
hören wollen, dann ist gut.
Und das kriegt jeder hin, der sich ein bisschen
vorbereitet. Da musst du dir keine Gedanken machen.
Du musst dir bloß unbedingt alte Prüfungen
angucken, so lange
bis du diesen IHK Style
der Fragestellung gecheckt hast.
Ja, genau so sind
die Fragen gestellt.
Genau so wird's in die Fragen gestellt.
Arbeitest ausschließlich
mit Mac.
Doch gut.
Die ganzen SQL Fragen und die fachlichen
Ja, aber das ist doch jedes Jahr
ist das doch immer mehr oder weniger das gleiche
was da dran kommt.
Und ein bisschen SQL Zeug
kann man schon
können als Fisi, unabhängig davon
ob man auf dem Mac arbeitet oder nicht.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Bei der IHK gibt's alles.
Wie tiefgehend sind die SQL Fragen da?
Kann mich ehrlich gesagt
nicht mal dran erinnern.
Wie tiefgreifend sind
die SQL Fragen in der IHK Prüfung?
Die können nicht
sonderlich kompliziert sein, weil ich hab's ja
offensichtlich geschafft. Und ich bin
echt kacke, was SQL angeht.
Okay, wenn MSSQL
so ein Tag drin ist, hätt ich auch verloren.
Ich hätte aber, was SQL angeht, schon bei deutlich
einfacheren Sachen verloren.
Also das höchste der Gefühle, was ich hinbekomme
in SQL ist ein Join.
Aber dann auch nur mit Gespicke.
Also ich krieg kein Join,
also nur mit Autocomplete.
Mit Autocomplete krieg ich ein Join hin, ansonsten nicht.
Das ist aber wirklich das
Maximum an SQL,
was ich hinkrieg.
Ja, sowas machen die gerne.
Was die auch gerne in Abschlussprüfungen machen,
ordnen sie die Gefahrensymbole
zu. Alter,
die IHK noch nicht mal Bilder dazu findet.
Kriegste dann
solche Dinge angezeigt
und sollst wissen, was es ist und so.
Das ist eine Frage,
die kriegst du als fiesi gestellt.
Richtig, das ist das eigentliche Problem
da dran.
Wie so IHK Style gestellt sind die Fragen.
Das ist das, woran man sich gewöhnen muss.
Damit bekommst du aber keine Punkte
bei der IHK.
Wie gesagt, realistische
2024 bezogene
Antworten gelten bei der IHK
Prüfung nicht.
Da muss genau das hin, was die hören wollen.
Ich musste das auch machen.
Ich musste, ich hab ja dort,
wo ich jetzt neu angefangen hab, musste ich ja auch
mindestens 7 verschiedene
Security-Schulungen und Unterweisungen
durchklicken und besuchen.
Und da kam auch dran, Gefahrensymbole
einordnen.
Wie ist die Rettungs-, wie heißt das Ding?
Rettungskette?
So mit Notarzt und
selbst in Sicherheit bringen
und Notarzt und
heißt das nicht Rettungskette?
Nicht Rettungsgasse, nein, nein, das meine ich nicht.
Heißt das nicht Rettungskette?
Heißt das
Rettungskette, oder?
Absichern, Eigenschutz, Notruf,
Sofortmaßnahmen, Erste Hilfe,
Rettungsdienst, genau.
Rettungskette.
Ja, das muss man dann auch,
ich hab übrigens schon
gehört, dass bei uns auf der Arbeit,
dass man cheaten kann.
Bei diesen
Tests.
Und zwar sind wohl die Tests
jedes Jahr die gleichen,
nur die Reihenfolge der Frage ist anders.
Das heißt, wir haben manche
Leute, die haben sich einfach Screenshots vom
Fragebogen gemacht und klicken das nächstes Jahr
wieder durch.
Sollte ich vielleicht auch machen.
Ein Effekt ist dann zwar weg,
aber damit kann ich leben.
Ich hab tatsächlich
diese Schulungsseite mit DevTools
noch nie angeguckt. Sollte ich vielleicht
mal machen, ja.
Easy findest du die Antworten im Internet.
Um welche Tests
geht's? Ja, man muss
auf der Arbeit,
zumindest ich musste das,
ist Pflicht, dass man einmal im
Jahr ein paar so,
wie nennt sich diese übergeordnete
Kategorie von Tests? Keine Ahnung.
Da muss man so
Sicherheitsunterweisungen
machen und danach muss man so einen
Multiple-Choice-Test ausfüllen, dass man verstanden hat,
wie man beim Brandfall
aus dem Gebäude kommt oder wie man
Terroristen erkennt und so. Ohne Scheiß, das war
eine Frage bei uns.
Ähm, also nicht wie man
Terroristen erkennt, aber
dass man,
dass man, was war die?
Genau, dass man Leute
melden soll, dass man Leute melden soll,
die Verdächtige, Verdächtige aktivieren,
Aktivitäten im Gebäude durchführen und sowas.
Und da hatten sie dann
bei so einem, bei einem Bild stand halt so
ein Koffer rum, so.
Was sagt ihr dazu,
Moment, was sagt ihr dazu,
nach der IT Kaufmann und drei Jahre Berufserfahrung
noch ein Wirtschaftsinformatikstudium
anzuschließen? Das musst du wissen, das kann man nicht
pauschal sagen.
Willst du dir wirklich noch ein Studium geben und wenn
ja, warum? Was ist
dein Hintergedanke, warum willst du das
Studium machen?
Ist es das Geld?
Da kann man nur
sagen, im Durchschnitt
statistisch gesehen
mag sich das lohnen. Im Durchschnitt
verdient jemand, der studiert hat, mehr als jemand, der
nicht studiert hat. Im Einzelfall
für dich muss sich das nicht unbedingt lohnen.
Es ist immer die Frage, warum du das
machen willst und ob du die Muße dazu hast, dir
das nochmal zu geben. Ob
du wirklich mehr Gehalt kriegst, kommt
auf dich an. Also das
ist, wie gesagt, im Durchschnitt
verdienst du mehr, wenn du studiert hast.
Für dich im Einzelfall muss das nicht der Fall
sein. Wenn du jetzt Ahnung hast
von dem, was du machst,
kannst du jetzt auch gut Kohle verdienen,
ohne dass du studiert hast.
Und durchaus mehr als jemand, der studiert hat,
aber nicht so den Durchblick hat.
Das kann man echt
schwierig sagen. Ich würde es davon abhängig
machen, also für mich kommt das gar nicht mehr in Frage.
Ich hätte gar keine
nicht das passende
Mindset für
nicht die Ausdauer
zu. Es ist die Frage, ob du dir das nochmal
wirklich geben willst, weil das ist schon
nicht ohne.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Es macht durchaus Sinn, solche
Schulungen durchzuführen, sehe ich auch so.
Zu lustig, die
sich teilweise erstmal anhören und
die Bildchen darin aussehen, das macht schon Sinn.
Normale Informatik
ist aber deutlich schwieriger, nochmal,
weil das
quasi ein Mathe-Studium ist, mit ein bisschen
Computer-Zeug dabei, erstmal.
Auf manchen Stellen brauchst du dich, ohne gar
nichts zu bewerben. Ehrlich,
mir fällt
von den letzten
boah, 100
Stellenanzeigen oder so, die wir uns angeguckt haben,
nicht eine ein, die explizit
jemand haben wollten, der studiert ist.
Meistens ist das vollkommen egal.
Bei irgendeinem Amt
vielleicht, aber ansonsten
so gut wie gar nicht.
Gibt Leute, die machen mit 30 nochmal eine Ausbildung.
Na wenn schon, müssen die
andere Seite das mit einrechnen.
Du musst dich einfach nur gut verkaufen.
Und wenn es
für den jeweiligen Beruf passt,
kann man ruhig ein bisschen
darauf rumreiten, dass man da schon
Vorkenntnisse hat, die man auch insofern belegen
kann und sie dementsprechend
quasi auch nicht die Kuh im Sack kaufen.
Ne, wie heißt das? Die Katze im Sack,
nicht die Kuh im Sack. Wie heißt das
Sprichwort mit der Kuh?
Die Katze im Sack kaufen.
Weil du davon ja Ahnung hast.
Aber ansonsten,
ich persönlich
finde ja Zertifikate meistens
enorm unsinnig und die ganze
dieses ganze Zertifikats Ökosystem
finde ich
unsinnig.
Aber mag sicherlich den
einen oder anderen geben,
der da drauf Wert legt.
Ich würde es nicht machen
und ich glaube bei den meisten
Unternehmen
ist das zumindest kein
festes
so Kriterium.
So nach dem Motto, wir nehmen niemand ohne
Zertifikat.
So
Ich kann noch was nachgucken.
Die Kuh vom Eis, genau.
Kann sein.
Kenn ich nicht.
Vielleicht bei irgendwelchen
BWL Sachen oder so.
Keine Ahnung.
Was manche Kunden vielleicht
verlangen ist, dass du
DIN ISO irgendwas zertifiziert
bist oder so. Das muss dann aber nicht du sein,
sondern der Laden in dem du arbeitest.
Also wie gesagt,
ich persönlich halte ja von Zertifikaten
gar nichts.
Chat, ich glaube ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Morgen früh aufwachen, streamen.
Kann sein, dass ich erst
wieder
am Ende so meines
normalen online
Zeitfensters da bin,
weil ich wieder meine 11km Runde
mach morgen früh.
Zumindest geplant nach
jetzigem Zeitstand.
Das heißt, wenn ich dann
aufstehe, so, keine Ahnung, kurz
vor 8, bin ich
eine Stunde am Rennen.
Kurz vor 9, ich muss noch
ein bisschen was essen.
Könnte dann durchaus eine Ecke nach 9 werden.
Spring erinnern, ja,
da habe ich gerade schon Bock.
Ja, ich glaube dann wird's
jetzt echt Zeit.
Also Leute, bis morgen, macht's gut.
See you.